in today's legal minute we are learning
how to protect our rights after an
accident Eric Palacios from Eric
Palacios and Associates the sponsors of
this segment tell us more
hi I'm Eric Palacios and welcome to the
legal minute today's question is how do
I protect myself after a car accident
number one call the police have the
police make a report without a police
report it can be difficult to establish
fault and obtain that other party's true
information number two seek medical
attention as soon as possible the longer
you wait the harder it is for you to
recover number three don't talk to the
insurance company they'll record your
statements and use them against you
later number four talk to an attorney as
soon as possible accident victims who
hire attorneys get on average seven to
ten times more compensation and finally
number five follow your doctor's advice
you might feel better right away but
always follow your doctor's
recommendations I'm Eric Palacios we'll
see you next time here on the legal
minute
give Eric Palacios and Associates a call
or visit their website Eric palacioslaw
right back
[Music]